I'll just go raise my spear to pack
welcome to the midnight game so oh [ __ ]
sorry first time in a long time it's
late as [ __ ] as I'm playing my Jason to
hold me there I'm all alone I don't know
it's like it changes a lot playing at
night and alone and oh god I'm dead the
rules are in front of me on the table or
I can't [ __ ] read with all right I'm
blind
switch lights off will be pain I believe
my switch bathroom what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do here it doesn't tell me
and oh what Oh what
what a wonderful poem who wrote this is
this the rules are me in front of the
table and then I check it and I can just
write the rules the rules are there are
no rules s s s s s best rules of my life
o interactive objects J oh I think I
just threw my ps3 controller into space
god damn it I hate when that happens
this strange Y vibe of this game makes
me feel like I'm the bad guy I don't
know why all right here's the key Neef
all right I got the knife all right what
else do I need a candle and some butter
it looks like okay there's supposed to
be a matchbox in here is that a matchbox
that's a toast they blurred out the name
for copyright genius next step is to
switch the lights off there's a master
switch outside the bathroom to the
bathrooms sweeted [ __ ] yeah best game
ever oh my god this is me like told you
oh I died well that was fun yeah I don't
know by you but the rules doesn't
[ __ ] work
goddamn Xbox you did it didn't you
oh these are their wills Oh write your
full name okay all right so I'm supposed
to write my name I should probably use a
fake name just first for it for
precaution
yep you never know there we go
what the [ __ ] is this what do I believe
in magic yes I do
so how do I take the knife thing I want
to put the knife on the paper
now with there we go it's shaking and
[ __ ] that's how legit it is the
narratives like you're gonna - ah shut
up your note okay knock on your own door
22 times [ __ ] me Anna it's like I don't
have anything better to do I guess
Oh God okay okay okay wait just help me
find the door just help me find the Gouy
ah I'm dead because I [ __ ] my you're
being way too complicated here man
it's a French pronunciation I say I say
I love si all right let's find all our
[ __ ] oh come on they're hiding by the
toaster now let's go and stab ourselves
because we have nothing better to do
make the note dance and jiggle that's
good then we need to find our entrance
before we turn off the lights is this it
oh my god this is it isn't it okay all
right
oh yeah oh [ __ ] I forgot about the
lights ah does this [ __ ] game hate me
all right
this is just to get the game started by
the way fam sex queer oughta New Year to
you
Alberto threatened puked on femto sexto
hold on Orton Nita shugie Shan [ __ ] oh
god I I did one too many Oh goddess I
mean I fail now come on
I just cuz I can't count to 20 - oh my
alright well hi there you go last chance
come on I'm actually getting nervous now
there's just too much tension building
up to this [ __ ] where is the midnight
man does he have nothing better to do at
midnight he should be sleeping god
damnit Sweden
all hail Sweden okay now we wait
if this doesn't work out I'll stab a
[ __ ] and that's [ __ ] will be Edgar
sorry ed Gary oh here we go here we go
what I did click oh my god oh you know
what this will make it worth it swear to
God if I [ __ ] up this time
seriously y22 is it really that much of
a jerk he's like I hit it knock 22 times
he only knocked 21 I'm not gonna [ __ ]
his [ __ ] up Ben 11 come on come on come
on come on I knocked I knocked what the
[ __ ] oh I didn't bring my note [ __ ] you
and all your rules we did it oh I didn't
think it was possible
all right let's lit this candle oh oh oh
oh oh oh that's fine oh my god let's
roll Ida sorry the rules it said step 4
immediately release your candle what did
i do what did I know why I let's take
this stupid note
and finish this [ __ ] [ __ ] I guess
since we have some time to talk what did
you do today that's very interesting
tell me more please then what happened I
can't believe that that is some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] out pardon me tell me more later
I have to continue alright can I lit my
candle or are you gonna cancel me out
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh for [ __ ] sake now I'm getting
really [ __ ] pissed the game that
doesn't want you to play it there we go
that's my [ __ ] name
let's try or I will [ __ ] eat my ass
what the [ __ ]
toaster go to space first I get killed
because i detonate lit the candle then I
get killed for light and candle
and then I just kill myself because he's
[ __ ] gay man oh please can I cut
myself some more
it's like blow out the candle
immediately relight your candle well
these make up your damn mind
we [ __ ] daddy I'm done we don't have
to play anymore alright alright alright
alright
hello midnight mine is IU he has to be
Swedish but I better talk Swedish Tim
Halle was such a low kicks it startles
me love
hello hello cake said Jackson daughter
out of spool up thought oh I don't spell
out all right there look that is me so
this is me when I see the midnight main
I'll just be like fangirling I'll be
like oh my god suck away all right let's
keep exploring oh shut up shut up oh god
what is happening what is ah I better
relate my candle then all right there we
go huh hello flaming rock will a no man
what the hell's going on here
ah I was like this is actually kind of
spooky let it up let that [ __ ] up there
we go
oh my god he's playing that well thing
to say a lot of money and groove I think
the spell out of nobody bleep you missed
ah
that was the scariest [ __ ] did you see
that toilet that was scarier than your
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] alright hello midnight
main like don't pretend to know me
midnight man that's uncool of you oh god
what was i I think he's playing the drum
or some [ __ ] I mean I mine what I tell
me about playing the drums god this
house is George going down in the
basement oh my god I would [ __ ] my ass
out
I am [ __ ] my barrels what are you
doing don't make me come to you can I
can I can I come why there's everywhere
all more matches sweet so the point is
to keep planning matches if I run out of
madness matches I'm dead there's a lot
of barrels down here I don't I don't
know about I feel like this I am NOT a
big fan of this I have been fan of a lot
of things in my days Backstreet Boys
even Westlife a little bit and even blue
they were pretty cool too actually
I picked up [ __ ] five match boxes how
did I get eight I know how to skate make
shudder oh god he did that thing oh god
what the [ __ ] is happening there no what
do you do what are you going
alright dude yep I've seen it all now ah
stop doing that ah oh that was close man
that was close man oh my god my ass just
dropped like a Nicki Minaj Hayes oh whoa
calm down calm down whatever happened
bookshelf I'm in I'm in that my and you
want a beer
lighten up man we can drink summon Oh Oh
where's that coming from
well I missed it I am NOT me stupid art
stop being hipster gatim chair gadem
stupid art I'm gonna run out of matches
if this continues that's for shizzle on
my pretzel if you know what I'm saying
Oh kid's room yes my just cool I need
tit tit milk think whoa that pillow
totally wanted to hug my face that's the
scariest thing that ever happened to me
I would say this besides blowing out my
candles midnight man is a pretty chill
guy you know I don't want to hate
without donate like so far oh my god he
smeared blood on my wall that [ __ ] is
dead
I just had that redone I don't care what
you say you gonna die
ah don't do that that's scary don't
scare me man I have feelings that needs
to be taken care of man I'm slipping
home alone tonight for the first time in
for a long time Oh God so don't know God
okay
it would suck so much ass if we [ __ ] up
because I don't I'm not capable of
letting a goddamn candle oh my god not
the toothpaste anything but the
toothpaste oh Jesus
all right I'm dead I'm dead you got me
Bravo I'm like flaming came for one and
a half [ __ ] hour
oh no he knows my name the midnight man
got me ha ha ha all right well done I
don't know I don't know what to say I am
just kind of tired and that took way
longer than I thought probably my fault
because I didn't figure how to play the
game it seems harder to start the
[ __ ] game that actually completed but
it wasn't I don't know it wasn't that
fun to be honest but I don't know I
don't know what are you brother think
let me know in the comments like if you
enjoy watching because I really
appreciate it I tried a hard hard ear
free bro
that's all for me hope you enjoyed stay
awesome buzz ha ha